well hello
today we've got with us leland miller
this is danielle dimartino booth with
with valuetainment economics
we bring you leland today because he is
the china data whisperer he knows more
about china
than all than most people in china know
uh but for those of you unfamiliar with
leland
and the china beige book first of all
let's jump in with asking leland
what got him so interested in following
china how did it start
well i grew up in dc and i grew up doing
china issues on capitol hill as a
teenager and
this sort of got me pulled into the into
the universe of u.s china policy
i went to college i studied mandarin uh
back then
it was the unfortunate situation where
if you were a spanish speaker or a
french speaker you couldn't take
spanish 101 or french 101 they didn't
have the rule for chinese native
speakers so i i took several years of
getting brutalized in chinese class
during college moved on i went to taiwan
did
graduate language training in mandarin
and went and got my masters in chinese
history afterwards
and then i sort of dove headfirst in the
corporate legal world
for a number of years doing law in new
york
and hong kong and eventually i just got
pulled
into a world of policy which was which
was which was captivating me a lot more
and within that world the most exciting
part of this
was the economics because there was very
little coming out and there's still
very little coming out that has to do
with
real data real information coming out of
china that's not
part of beijing's own narrative
own trumpeting of its own reality so
um i guess you could say that it's kind
of an open
secret if you will that what you're
talking about that the chinese data
are manufactured that they're massaged
that they fit a narrative
um what should
why should the average layperson be
concerned
with data coming out of china uh i mean
the last
well i did a little bit of homework
before this and i think the last time
china had as large of an economic
footprint
was maybe in the year 700 if i'm
remembering correctly that in terms of
the size of the global
economy but maybe you can walk us
through kind of the past
20 30 years and the evolution of
china's rise as a global economic
superpower which i think we could argue
that they certainly are
um and then and then bring into it
data and how data should form the way we
think and see
and perceive the country right well 20
30 years ago
china was a very developing
economy it didn't have that large of an
economic footprint
you know look you look right now it's
the second largest largest economy in
the world
uh the largest number of of people in
the world it's an enormous
enormous country on the rise and what's
interesting is that despite the fact
that we've seen this
enormous emergence of china over the
past 20 or 30 years
markets in general have been rather
complacent about getting better
information
out of it i mean think about u.s
information there is a u.s
indicator for everything imaginable you
go to europe
every single type of uh information
micro and macro
you can get that information if you
don't someone will invent it soon enough
that's not the case in china you know
we're still treating china like it's
this baby economy from 20 or 30 years
ago
because only markets are only relying
on information coming out of beijing and
a handful of smaller indicators now run
by large by chinese companies it doesn't
give the full picture on china and
even if all the data coming out of
beijing
did give you unblemished truth they
never lied they never manipulated they
never juiced any piece of data
the problem is they don't put out that
much of it so they leak out what they
like
they leak out certain amounts and then
markets are left to grasp with
how does how does one sector look
against another regionally what's the
difference between a coastal china and a
periphery china
and so right now despite the fact that
there are
hundreds of billions of dollars of
commerce going back and forth between
the us and china and
europe and china and it's its global
commerce center
you just don't have that much
information coming out of it and what
you do
is filtered through the government lens
so it's a very unique
and quite problematic situation to be in
so uh can you can you kind of quantify
if you will
china's global footprint how big china
is
whether you're talking about gross
domestic product the size of their
economic output or
as that of an exporting nation as well
as the rise of
the the chinese consumer which i think
is one of the least
appreciated stories in the past five or
ten years
right well some of my information on gdp
may be a little bit outdated but
you know essentially you're looking at
it at a gdp number in the teens
in the low teens uh or almost to the low
teens
the u.s is close around 20 trillion and
you've got a
you've got a chinese number that's it's
maybe 11 or 12.
um but you know it's it's the reason
that i don't pay attention to it that
much is that as you say
there's a lot of different ways to look
at china and one of the worst
is to look at the gdp number because
china has always had this enormous
fixation on the gdp number because
big growth equals big success but that's
not what happens
and what you see is that this has become
a part of the chinese model
whereas you know if the chinese want to
hit a certain economic number
then they'll just build so the old joke
was
you know if you want to hit eight
percent gdp you build a bridge you tear
it down
you build the same bridge again you tear
it down you build the same bridge again
you tear it down and you keep going
until you hit your gdp number
because gdp measures aggregate growth
and not productive growth
and the largest problem with the chinese
economy right now is there's not enough
productivity baked into what they're
doing
enormous non-performing loans enormous
waste enormous inefficiencies and
they're trying to get away from it but
it's very difficult
for after decades of being trained to
focus on
growth at all costs and i think the
other way to look at this of course
is if you look at per capita gdp let's
assume that that hasn't
has meaning uh right now china has 1.4
billion plus
people so there's still a developing
economy they're still nowhere near
uh nowhere near uh middle-income
[Music]
levels of growth and which would make
them in the same ballpark as japan
or europe or united states it's still a
very poor country and it's a country
that's getting older
so on the one hand you've got this
extraordinary economic powerhouse
tons of people tons of economic growth
on the other hand
you've got this enormous population
that's very poor it's very male
it's very old and so there are these
these obstacles to china
jumping to the next step that are not
the same things that we saw with the
asian tigers that we saw with the u.s in
the early days that we saw in europe
so china's got their own unique set of
problems right now that they're trying
to work through
so um the china watching industry
uh i mean i've i've been on
on wall street i've been in investments
i've been a federal reserve insider
i've played all kinds of roles and worn
all kinds of hats
but the china watching industry seems to
be something
that has evolved
explain to us how it used to work
and how it works today and um
the catchphrase that you mentioned that
the
derivative the first derivative of crap
is still crap
so uh walk me through that yeah
i'm trying to keep that from being our
company motto but uh
the way this has always worked is that
because there's been this focus on china
but not ever a desire to hold
chinese uh to hold beijing accountable
for good
data to create new sources of data
there's always been this idea that
because china's communists
it's a black box it's opaque you cannot
get that out of it
and because of that you just have to
accept whatever they give you and
that's as good as it gets now the fact
that i'm here speaking
to you right now shows that that's
that's not the truth but it's
something that people have held as truth
for for a number of years now
back in the old day when people were
really focused even more than they are
now
on china's quarterly growth numbers but
also some of these monthly industrial
output
you know retail sales consumption
numbers what the chinese
government would do invariably is set
out a list of
forecasts for what numbers they wanted
to hit they were head targets
and then they would always hit those
targets with a little bit of movement on
each side
so if you could read chinese and you
knew who to follow
his former monetary policy economist
former uh beijing insiders you could
read
the chinese press understand where they
were predicting growth
you knew that chinese government was
going to always hit their targets
so these this china watching industry
for
multiple decades was based around the
idea
not on quantifying data not on research
not on any doing any doing any real work
it was about understanding what
beijing's targets are understanding that
they were always going to hit those
targets
and then predicting them before anyone
else in the western press saw it and
hey you're a china analyst and that that
world existed for a long
long time and the funny thing about this
is
you know we're in 2020 now and when we
first started china baseball back in
we and i told i told my team we probably
have two or three years
before the whole world catches up with
us does the same thing as we're trying
to do which is trying to get real data
real big data out of the chinese economy
because in today's world where
everything runs on big data
numbers algorithms how could you not go
in that direction
so i figured we had about two or three
years before everybody else chased after
us
and and we were in a dog fight for who
had the best data you know a decade
later
and we are the only people still who are
doing large-scale
private data inside the chinese economy
so a what is
a china beige book i i used to work at
the fed i know what the beige book is
for the fed i know that that is a an
anecdotal gathering that you can
eventually quantify and make into
into data that gives you a feel for how
different aspects
of the geographic us economy are and
of the sectorials different sectors here
and there of the us economy
it all comes together in a big book how
what what is the china beige book first
of all
well china beige book obviously modeled
itself
at least at the very beginning off what
the federal reserve preserve does what
you're talking about the beige book
and the beige book for the united states
is something that is qualitative
you know the various districts as you
know have reports coming in from their
business leaders and their companies and
they sort of put together this
qualitative
uh sketch of the entire country uh from
the ground up
and this was very different than the
other kind of data you're seeing the
markets we're using which is heavily
quantitative
and heavily macro and so this provided a
new flavor
now when we went into china to try to
figure out the best way
of attacking the idea of data collection
you know we started with the beige book
model a beige book esque model
which was heavily qualitative we were
asking firms for their qualitative views
and then we had the other half was
quantitative and what we figured out
very quickly was that who cares about
the qualitative stuff
the reason that the beige book in the
united states was different and useful
is that the quantitative stuff had
already been done and so this provided a
new wrinkle
what we were realizing is we're the only
person
we're the only team doing quantitative
data in china
so we started reducing the footprint on
the qualitative side
over the course of the first 18 months
until we eliminated entirely
and now we are a quantitative look at
the economy
and what that means is you know you look
at uh you look at indicators right now
they come out with a couple hundred
firms
we survey over 3 300 firms we release
data eight times a year
we track seven different sectors we
track 34 discrete
sectors but we don't just focus on
growth
you know if you if you're used to
getting a number in the press for how's
china
doing you either see like a six percent
gdp number or a
50.2 uh pmi number nobody knows what
those numbers mean
and what we figured out very quickly as
well is that just having the idea
that growth can be boiled down to one
number is too simplistic
so we started tracking growth and of
course tracking all
output and cash flow and all these other
growth indicators sales revenue etc
but we also tracked the labor market
which was being ignored
and we also attract inflation which
wasn't getting enough attention
and what we did that was really the
breakthrough for us is we are the only
people in the world
outside china's central bank who track
the credit market
and we're not just tracking what's
happening at banks we're tracking what's
happening inside
of china's shadow banks so we ask these
thousands of firms
how much they're borrowing what they're
borrowing for how much they're paying
and we can track china's growth and
predict china's growth
using credit as a lens it's a very very
powerful tool for us
well i get all that um but what i don't
get is
why anybody's actually talking to you do
they not have
the fear of a big brother well we don't
operate on the ground as china baseball
that's one thing
so we do have talking
we do have a special sauce that keeps us
as under the radar as possible
uh but look when you're doing the only
large-scale private data in the world in
the chinese economy
and you're reporting like we are right
now the growth is actually much
weaker than what beijing is claiming
then you have a spotlight on you you
have a
target on you and the the question
obviously is
why are we allowed to do what we do and
i think
a lot of it comes down to the fact that
no one in beijing no one in china likes
the idea of us
talking to newspapers and talking to
people like yourselves and saying
chinese economic debt is fake and the
econom
economic narrative is fake and you know
they manipulate their numbers when they
don't like them
that's not very popular in china but
what they found over time
is that there is an enormous concern
over where china is going and what
china's hiding
and so a handful of times over the past
decade when
markets have really gotten panicky about
what's happening in china
and capital starts flowing out of there
usually
and markets start crashing august 2015
was the was the
most obvious example this but we saw in
2016 we saw in 2013
what were we doing at the time you know
we reported back to our clients
uh made sure they were they knew what
was going on and then we went public
with the idea that look
this may look like a hard landing to you
but we've got data in front of us and
things are not nearly as bad as you
think
a hard landing has been described you
know in
in this any scare pieces in the press
are not happening here's our data
here's what it says and this is why you
have to worry about this
and why you don't have to worry about
that and over time what we were told at
least informally
from the chinese government is that we
don't like what you say a lot of the
time
but you have proven yourself over time
to not have
a greater agenda you're not a bear
you're not someone
talk their book you're not someone out
to get china what you're doing is you're
calling balls and strikes
and a lot of times that means calling
china out for having
juiced up data and occasionally it means
calming markets who are too panicky
about something that's actually not
happening inside the economy
that must make you really popular with
people who are talking their books
the word talking their books is we're
talking about people who go on
bubble vision and and take one side or
another of any given
potential profit-making idea trade idea
well it's a major problem with not just
the china watching industry but finance
at large i mean how many people do you
see out there on tv talking talking idea
talking idea
you find out why why are they telling
people that because they've got their
money in it they have no credibility
so one of the reasons we're different
than these other entities that are out
there
commenting on uh the chinese economy is
that
we don't have a stake in anything except
getting it right
if we get it right we'll have a
flourishing company if we get it wrong
we'll lose all our clients
you know you compare that to what
happens at the investment banks right
now
they have a million different agenda
items and
getting the data right is about 900th on
the list
you know close to the top would be
getting more asset management business
from china
getting more underwriting deals from
china you know making sure that
uh they're getting 100 percent of their
securities ventures granted permission
for
100 security ventures that they're
trying to uh establish on the mainland
they've got a lot of business
opportunities
which incentivize them to not just tamp
down
the message but sometimes to completely
silence people within their ranks who
who have an alternative message which is
maybe china's not doing as good a job
maybe beijing is not orchestrating
this magical economic movement that
they're claiming and one of the problems
is that almost everybody who's got a
finger in this china pie
is talking their book has something to
be gained by their own theme and that's
something we've tried
very very hard to stay away from
so um how
how open is china to
to foreign investment how open is china
to companies who
want you to us companies that want to
come in and set up shop
how successful has corporate america
and wall street and the banking u.s
banking system how successful have they
been
at making inroads on the mainland
i'd say very unsuccessful there have
been success stories and there will
continue to be success stories china has
enormous
opportunities out there because of the
size the economy so you will see firms
doing really well
but i think that if you had to grade the
overall effort the grade would be very
very low simply because china made
a lot of promises back in the early
2000s when there was
you know the wto accession and you know
we're going to open our economy we're
going to do this
decades past and nothing had happened
now you've seen a lot of headlines
recently about
china opening its economy to banks or
credit card companies or insurance firms
and that's wonderful
but it's also too late they're competing
against
scots entities chinese champions
who are already in there they're you
know u.s banks are not going to go into
china and take business away
materially away from chinese banks
you're not going to see
mastercard and visa and american express
going to china
and take business away from these
ensconce
chinese e-commerce champions so china
waited and it deleted a dallied and
and now it's slowly opening up because
it meets the capital it's being
pressured on the trade side
and that's all great but the but the
real opportunity to have gone in
and competed it's gone so
you will see success stories but overall
this this is drawn this is dragged out
for too long and
and and now foreign companies are the
losers in this and i don't think there's
anything you can do about it
yeah i i think i heard some anecdote
about about
alibaba and the sheer the size of their
footprint when it comes to
transactions i just i don't know how you
would get something like that
unentrenched if you will um
yeah it's impossible to to to compete
with a company like alibaba
who on the one hand extremely innovative
extremely
talented workforce it's a great company
but it also
has beijing also has its back and when
you have
when you have those two things together
it's just impossible to compete with and
that's that's the the problems corporate
foreign corporates have had in china for
years and years
so what do you say to people who say
that that china has built up
so much debt that it is an accident
waiting to happen
it's an economy that's going to implode
under its own weight
it's it's it's there there's no such
thing as a scenario that can be painted
for there not to be a hard landing i
mean i hear it all
the time not only do i not think that a
hard landing is inevitable i don't even
think it's likely
and let me explain why hard landing
first of all
has taken on many many different
connotations over the years so so back
when china was growing at eight percent
a year
there were people out there who said if
china's growth falls to six percent or
so
that's a hard landing so one of the ways
that people have gotten away with having
wrong
predictions for years and years and
years has been you just
changed the goal you move the goal post
back so it went it's a growth number
the way that i look at hard landing is i
look at sort of an implosion an acute
crisis in china and i don't think that
is
likely what's happening right now is an
enormous problem with bad debt
uh the debt that is recognized as
non-performing
uh by beijing is a fraction of what's
actually non-performing non-performing
loans
technical term there's a multi-tier
classification system and when the bad
debt gets too too high in one category
they sort of just push it down
and lower the non-performing loan
numbers uh
so they're two percent you know a lot of
people think that they're over 20
percent
so there's no question nobody can test
the idea that china has way too much bad
debt
and that this is causing a severe
problem and a severe challenge
to china's economic model the question
is what's going to happen next
and what i think most people miss in
this is that
china does not have a commercial
financial
system a lot of people looked at what
happened to the united states in 2008
and europe
slightly after and and saw the economy
sort of implode because
parties stopped loaning to each other
you got a liquidity crisis you had all
these things happen
because these western banking systems
were commercial financial systems
and what you have in china is something
different the state controls all the
counterparties
and so what happens when you have a
problem in china is you have one side of
the of the state apparatus just
swoosh a tidal wave of capital from one
side whether it's from from this fund or
from this bank
to plug a hole on that side and then one
side swoosh capital the other side
uh to constantly plug holes now what
happens there
is you fix the short term problem but
you're constantly pushing
bad money after good and you're
constantly
creating less return on investment less
productivity
so potential growth rates will never
outpace the growth of debt
and that's a very technical way of
saying that the more china just
takes all its big ball of cash is kept
toward it
and sort of throws its problems one by
one it can deal with problems in the
short term
it can deal with them much better than a
western economy for instance
but the problem is over time it's chased
all their good
all their good money is chasing bad
they've got a system that's slowed down
and stagnated and i think that's the
future of china you've got a stagnated
economy
that's growing at one percent
going forward and and that's a real
structural problem and i think one of
the reasons you're seeing so much
hesitancy on going big right now in
china despite the
closing economy is that beijing
understands
even if western economists don't
understand that the debt
problem is so severe that if they don't
reverse some of this or at least slow it
down
then they're going to be in enormous
trouble going forward with an economy
that's just standing still
in in just a number of years so
um china has been i mean
maybe we cannot necessarily see
true chinese data from chinese
authorities
but we can see with our own eyes the
effect that chinese growth has had on
the rest of the world
so what are the implications for what
you're describing leland i mean
you're talking about this this is going
to affect continents
i mean who who will this hurt the most
and i mean you can't you can't a day
doesn't go by when you don't hear about
dr copper
and copper price is going up so much and
steel price is going up so much
there's this ongoing embedded assumption
that china's always going to be driving
the commodities complex so that but what
you're talking
about sclerosis stagnation these are not
exactly dynamic
adjectives to describe a country that's
going to continue to be
the consumer of first and last resort no
that's exactly right i mean the people
that are at
the most risk here aren't even in china
because china's got some
china's got some structural questions it
has to answer and it's going to have to
deal with slower growth
either because it restructures its
economy
towards slower healthier growth that's
less debt fueled that's that's more
based on a
on consumption and less the state sector
uh
sucking sucking out of the second the
private sector out of existence
if it does it right that's what happens
if it doesn't then this goes until
you have more of a problem and you start
seeing a dramatic slowdown and
all the loans in the world into the
chinese economy
don't make chinese firms want to borrow
because they see an uncertain future
they don't like they don't like what's
ahead of them and you're going to see a
substantial
growth slide in china no matter what the
good case the best case scenario the
worst case scenario
but china can get out the other side in
one piece
and become an emerging power this isn't
the end of china this is a
major metamorphosis of china the
countries that are in real trouble here
are the ones that have been looking to
the chinese economy
as this demand center that will keep
their economies going indefinitely
now you mentioned commodities producers
these are the worst of the bunch
you see you look at all these economies
out there that have been
instead of diversifying themselves away
from
uh commodities just just cranking out
stuff they can shift to china
what they've been doing is just relying
on this growth relying on chinese
promises that look at this will continue
indefinitely and they haven't done
enough structural changes to their own
economy
so as chinese demand falls over the
course of
uh of the coming years and decades
you're going to have a real
problem in all these places that have
relied on chinese demand and chinese
consumption
and it's just now occurring to some of
these countries that they have to do
something about it
and we're gonna see if it's too late but
this is the real problem this this
belief in eight percent forever
which the chinese pushed as this party
slogan was taken
way too seriously by the whole world for
way too long and now you're going to
have severe
severe dislocations as a result of this
over the coming years
so uh what were the top five most
affected economies be i mean i
i spent 10 days in australia recently i
can tell you there's
there's made in china's everywhere there
whether you're talking about real estate
or their biggest port
right well australia's on the list uh
you know we talk about south africa we
talk about brazil
uh there's actually a uh quite a few
south american countries that might be
on that list
if they're if they're cranking out a lot
of uh uh producing a lot of commodities
and a lot of it's shipping to china then
that's a real problem and you know right
now there's so much fear about growth
that the chinese may actually be dub
you know backing into their old playbook
of using some heavy property growth
in order to in order to get the growth
numbers up so this may be sending some
false signals to people out there that
hey maybe this model is not dead
the model's dead they may just try to
they're just trying to squeeze a little
bit more out of it
before it before it suffocates so as an
as an economic historian i can tell you
the only time in
the past 100 years that you've seen
a commodity super cycle like we had seen
before come to a screeching halt
uh and stay low for longer than anybody
was anticipating
was during the great depression that's
the only time we've seen that
well we're going to see that to some
degree going forward it's just a
question of how much longer
china wants to push growth higher
at the expense of its future and that's
a decision made in beijing but it's a
it's a decision that we track with our
data and try to make sure
we're understanding the types of policy
calls they're making
as they make them so i've written
in the past uh the term quiet colonizer
carmen reinhardt has written extensively
about this
uh how has china
expanded its its its presence globally
what mechanism has it used uh especially
in africa
well one of the major foreign policy
tools
the chinese communist party has is to
loan money
out to firms around the globe and then
use that as leverage for
either foreign policy or economic
reasons a lot of these deals are not
done above the table
uh there's enormous there was enormous
push into africa in order to secure
agricultural lands now commodities and
other things that they
the chinese economy needed in order to
keep it going
this is something that scared it scared
everybody for a long time but we're also
seeing the the problems the chinese are
encountering because of this
so they're deep into central asia
they're deeper into south asia and
africa and and elsewhere and chinese
money is out there
pushing policy but at the same time
quite a lot of this money will never get
pushed back people could ever never get
paid back
uh you've also got a situation where
when the chinese do business abroad
they don't just hand out money they send
chinese workers they like to keep some
of these workers employed and there have
been enormous hostilities in africa and
central asia elsewhere
some of this related to the one belt one
road uh program
where instead of these countries think
that they're taking money in and they're
going to be able to use them for
employment and all these other wonderful
reasons
but the next thing they see is is uh you
know tens of thousands of chinese come
in and they're setting up shop and
temporary barracks and they're doing the
work so
none of this is as clear-cut as i think
a lot of people thought a few years ago
there was a huge fear that china was
taking over the world through this and i
think now
there's much more of a fear that china
has thrown their money around
they're never going to get it back and
they've made a few quite a few enemies
along the way so it's a mixed bag but
it's much more of a mixed bag than
people
understood at the time when everyone was
scared to death of what china was doing
well a lot of these countries you're
talking about are taking money right now
from the international monetary fund and
in a million years well that's an
exaggeration but in a very long time
will not have the wherewithal
to pay back what they owe china um
so there was a time not too long ago
that
china had four trillion dollars in
foreign reserves first of all can you
explain what that concept means
in layman's terms and it's it's come
down to three trillion dollars
but is that a real number it's not a
real number but it's a number that
markets look at policymakers look at
so so we take we take seriously uh it it
is a real number but
it's not the number let me let me
rephrase uh what i mean by that is so so
when
china has a non-convertible currency you
can't just take the wall and exchange it
however you want you you when when
dollars go into
the chinese economy uh their exchange
for yuan those dollars and china sells
something into the united states
and it's paid for in dollars right and
as those dollars go to chinese companies
they
exchange them for yuan on the mainland
they're required to and
so what basically happens is that the
chinese
government has an enormous storage of
this forex reserves now it's not a piggy
bank
it's marked against actual obligations
at these chinese companies but it means
that there's a huge
uh forex reserve of u.s
dollars mostly u.s dollars that are that
are there in order to sort of backstop
the obligations on the iran
and back a few years ago earlier in xi
jinping's
uh tenure you saw
the chinese numbers cross 4 trillion in
forex reserves
and 4 trillion dollars and the big worry
in beijing was that the number was
getting so big
they were going to have to find reasons
to recycle this money into the global
economy
or else they were going to start having
political problems with folks around the
world
for trade reasons and for other reasons
there was this was going to become a
political issue because they
forex reserves were too high so that's
when belton road started gaining a lot
of steam that's when a lot of these
other programs
started getting a lot of steam but what
happened in the time since
you know they had a forex crisis that
there was a there was some panics
2016 the number dropped to 3
trillion-ish
and in fairness to the chinese
that number is not the number people
should be looking at there are numbers
there's far more capital within the
banking system
that china could draw on if there was
ever a true
capital outflow crisis so the forex
number
is important it's not the only number we
should be looking at and what happened
in 2016 i think was oversold to a great
degree
which is why you never saw the
devaluation of the currency that
everyone predicted
uh but i think that the number does have
import because when you got down to 3
trillion all of a sudden
you went from the world saying china's
got way too much is a problem saying
wait a second
china's got a whole lot of obligations
and a whole lot of debt is three
trillion enough
and then you start to have worries about
solvency and the workability of the
chinese economic model
and so now you're in a position where xi
jinping has already backed
one belt one road although they're
pulling it back his fingerprints are on
that so you can't just make this thing
go away
but they don't have the type of capital
they need in order
to put all these global programs into
fruition whether it's central asia again
whether it's africa whether it's south
america whether it's somewhere else
so they're at a very difficult jam
whereas they don't have the type of
financial firepower to be able to
keep these programs going the way they
first they intended them back in 2013 or
2014.
and it's a rhetorical problem for the
party uh but it's also uh an economic
management issue for the party right now
so they're trying to figure out how they
continue to talk big
about their outward push right during a
time
where the chinese economy more and more
needs to pull in capital
in order to be able to function well
we know that they've got something on
their hands uh rare earth metals first
of all
let's just let's just say for example
that people don't know what rare earth
metals are but they've become pretty
important
and help us explain help us understand
why
rare earth metals have become so
important and
what the implications are for countries
outside of china
well rare earth metals are they are what
they they sound like they're they're
certain uh elements that are only uh
available in certain place around the
globe
china has an enormous stock of them
they're not available uh
mostly outside of china with a handful
of exceptions
uh and these are the types of things
that will go into you know electric
vehicle batteries and
and very very important new age
technology
and what happened a number of years ago
is that china
uh was making some international plays
to secure even more
uh of their of these rare earth metals
to to get it basically a monopoly on it
and people started sniffing around
saying what's going on here this is a
real
supply chain vulnerability uh pretty
much the the origin of the worries on
supply chains
came from the rare earth's metals a
number of years ago and
you started seeing this become a big
policy issue in japan
and the united states is saying wait a
second we can't let china create this
chokehold on these important rare earth
elements or they're going to have this
ability to shut down
foreign production and this is when
people's eyes started to get opened up
that by allowing the chinese to have
choke points in the supply chain in this
case
rare earth metals you could be
endangering part of your own econo
economy you could be endangering some of
your your next generation sectors
and this is where people started getting
smart on it and uh and now we're looking
at this
it would it would be an enormous problem
for china if it actually cut this off
it you know this is a this is an act of
economic warfare
to cut out these these components
from the japanese from the americans
from elsewhere but the problem is right
now
china has less leverage than it would
like
over a lot of its trading partners so
things that a couple of years ago would
have seemed outlandish to consider why
would china ever consider doing that
all of these things are now possible and
it's why policymakers in particular
are starting to sort of re-evaluate
where these vulnerabilities are in the
supply chain and supply chain
issues have gone from an afterthought at
corporates and after thought in congress
to being one of the most pressing issues
of the year for 2020.
well look the conversation that we just
had the explanation that you just gave
could just as easily
have been applicable to the
pharmaceuticals industry in a
post-covered world
i mean do you see do you see concerted
efforts
in congress inside the beltway in
washington dc
uh to make sure that we in the future
because i know a lot of americans are
very focused on this that we never
let this happen again so to speak
uh on pharma yes uh so we work with a
lot of
companies and what and what's important
to understand these supply chain issues
the supply chain problems and the supply
chain responses that corporates have
it's not monolithic so you have some
companies like pharmaceuticals which are
going to be
over have heavy government oversight
there's a national security component as
we've seen because of covid
and there is going to be a push from
politicians
to solve this you're going to see other
types of companies whether it's car
companies whether it's it companies with
parts
they're working to try to untangle
themselves in these supply chains
but there's less of an urgency there are
less options because they don't have
these type of
production options outside of china
quite yet so there's no supply chain
solution but there is a realization
across corporate america and and
global corporates that something has to
be done
and the old way was how do we get things
as cheap as possible in order to make
the share price go up
and now people are realizing whether
it's because of the trade war or
geopolitical
tensions or coven 19 that it's no longer
acceptable to tell shareholders you
don't have a plan b
or a plan c so now every corporate is
being forced to go into a war room and
think
how do we create fewer vulnerabilities
in our supply chains
this is a process that's happening
everywhere we're involved with a lot of
companies doing this
but i think pharma be brought up was in
particular
that's in the government crosshairs
there's been an executive order drafted
on this it's sort of sitting on trump's
desk waiting for hip to sort of push
this forward
but this is political issue major
political issue
some of the other supply chain issues
aren't aren't quite as political but wow
this is something that's
that's absolutely taking up bandwidth on
capitol hill in the white house right
now
speaking of bandwidth on capitol hill um
to hong kong it's a huge subject
we we've seen night after night of
footage
and then covet came and that seemed to
have tamped down
but boy is it ramped back up again um
first of all at the most basic level
hong kong was handed back from the
british
a few years back 1997 i think you can
correct me
what role has it played in the
mainland's economy
since then because you look at per
capita growth in hong kong you look at
per capita growth
on the mainland and they're they're
they're right there on top of each other
obviously
and they're day and night what role has
hong kong played
well in some ways it played this bridge
between china and the west
because it allowed china to be
capitalist and
free-market-ish and western uh
but not have to change the mainland
economy not not not have to
to make a political call on this they
simply accepted what was handed to them
and allowed hong kong to play this
pivotal role
uh as this asia the centerpiece of asian
commerce
and you had western bankers interacting
with chinese bankers and
it was this really had this really
unique role because it was part of china
but it was part of the west
and what you've seen over the course of
the past six weeks or so
has been the end of that the end of hong
kong as we know it
the chinese ripped back uh their promise
of one country two systems
and when they did this the political
choice for
for for the united states was do we do
we treat hong kong
the way it was or do we treat it as just
another
chinese province and i think that there
was a
there was a lot of wait and see within
the white house on how do we
how do we move forward this but when the
actual
national security law was written in
beijing and people saw what it said
and it allowed it was it was so much
more draconian than anyone thought
it allows secret service to operate all
throughout china
it allows people to be extradited back
to beijing it has an extra
territoriality clause which allows
the chinese to arrest
anyone doing anything in the entire
world outside of hong kong or outside of
china
it's doing anything counter to what to
to uh to to the hong kong system
to the chinese communist party's belief
in how hong kong should run
so this was a absolute worst case
scenario scenario
for uh for the law it was way worse than
anyone i know
had predicted it and as a result the the
us in the last several you know
weeks has moved forward to treat
hong kong again like china they've got
they're getting their tariff uh
privileges revoked so now tariffs are
going to be applied to hong kong the
same way they are made with china
export controls have been pulled back
and the sad you know the sad part of
this
is this vibrant hong kong democracy this
vibrant hong kong economy
is is gone it it will never be this way
again
and and but you you describe something
that is akin to china shooting itself in
the foot
why did china you would think that this
would have been world's most convenient
conduit
why did why why was china so dead set on
pushing forward with this
if hong kong provided such a vital
financial intermediary role
uh to the mainland especially now when
when you think about the chinese economy
as being
as you describe in a fairly vulnerable
position
right i think the answer that is because
because china
beijing thought it was losing hong kong
and you had a calendar that's very
specific
to hong kong on this you know people
look at what's happening in hong kong
the tragedy of hong kong right now
and they sort of want to place this in
the u.s china
uh tension battle they want to see this
as some sort of big
chess piece in the global you know the
global competition between the west and
china
sure it plays that role but what
actually was happening in in
in hong kong was you added some
elections that were scheduled
for september and there was a very small
window
for beijing to step in and change the
political rules
otherwise what was going to happen in
september was going to be what happened
in the next
in the previous election which was all
the pro-beijing forces were going to get
routed
and when beijing looked at this they
said wow we are going to get enormous
blowback
from changing the rules in hong kong we
know it but if we let this
happen and we let hong kong basically
toss out
uh its pro it's pro beijing forces you
might have an even bigger problem down
the road
and i think with the political problems
that xi jinping has had at home
with looking about at taiwan and
basically the the trade war
xi jinping has had a very bad last
couple of years and when he looked at
hong kong i think the decision was made
that this is gonna this is gonna be
painful
but if we don't do this now we may have
to do something
far far far worse later and that's why
the decision was made
to push upon hong kong a national
security law that now criminalizes
anything that beijing doesn't like
so this is strong arming as opposed to
sending troops in the streets
right and and you know the the the the
issue was always that the beijing was
never going to
have a tiananmen like uh charge into
hong kong simply because it owned
it owned hong kong beforehand it has
prepared for this
for 20 30 years you have you would just
have people sucked off the street
and arrested and you
this this is a very difficult time it
was a very difficult
decision for beijing to make but it
wasn't one between a full-on crackdown
at this point
and a political crackdown but i think
that what was going through their heads
in beijing was
we can't lose hong kong anymore because
if it if
if it's any further out of our orbit if
it flies any further out of our orbit
then we may actually have to bring in
the guns
and that's where they moved um
there's a lot of talk about the dollar
peg first of all
what is a dollar peg just in case people
don't know
and what is the future of the hong kong
dollar peg
well the question first of all how a
dollar peg is when
a currency decides with either within a
band or a particular number typically
within a band
decides to say we are going to be x
amount of
hong kong dollars to the us dollar uh or
just x amount of chinese yuan to the us
dollar
and we're going to allow our central
bank to
keep it within that ban the market can
move within a small ban but we're going
to keep this thing locked in a pretty
tight
tight band and because we like the
stability of the u.s dollar
we don't we want to ground everything
we're doing and the fact the us dollars
is global reserve currency
and we want to to pile on that stability
for our own purposes
now when people talk about the hong kong
dollar peg collapsing either because the
u.s takes it down which i can tell you
is not being considered right now
or because the chinese do something to
cause some sort of problems that
snowball into
this becoming a political weapon you
have to ask yourself who will this
benefit who will be punished who will
benefit i don't think there's anyone out
there who's going to do terribly well
other than a few uh hedge funds if the
hong kong dollar peg
would go completely so it's not in
china's interest right now
it's not in hong kong's interest it's
not in the u.s interest so when people
talk about taking down this hong kong
peg i i i try to push them back on this
it doesn't serve a purpose it wouldn't
serve a purpose and so let's hold our
horses on think that this is part of the
uh
financial warfare that we would be
considering well
so talk us about uh
what economic warfare is going on right
now
and what china's doing right now to
to maintain its position on the global
stage and i mean specifically vis-a-vis
the united states
well we're not in we're not yet at a
position
where economic warfare is is is being
utilized between the two countries but
it's being threatened and that's why
this is very different than the last few
years so one of the most obvious
examples of this is
banking sanctions so the new legislation
that congress passed in a bipartisan
fashion
and that president trump signed has the
potential
for individuals who are uh designated as
as being troublemakers in in in hong
kong because they are
furthering the crackdown or doing
something at dissidents uh
not only are they being targeted but any
banks that work with those individuals
we targeted now the administration
stepped in and made these things
discretionary rather than mandatory
because they didn't want to get sucked
down
a an alley where all of a sudden things
are going
escalating out of their control so
banking sanctions would be one
major way for the u.s and china to
ratchet up tensions enormously and
markets
of course would take notice of this uh
you have anything involved
with uh us dollars so right now the u.s
dollar is provided to hong kong
hong kong dollar peg you know i just
said that it's very very unlikely they
would
they would uh play around they toy
around with the hong kong dollar peg
but providing dollars uh to to hong kong
providing dollars
to chinese entities very very important
and so when we talk about red lines and
what the red
line of the red lines are and what the
biggest baddest red lines are
really the one that would really shape
beijing it would be
uh tantamount to an act of war would be
cutting off uh important beijing
institutions entities possibly but
individuals
from the us dollar system uh we talk
about that through swift which is the
sort of payment international payment
mechanism
uh for doing this but any type of
utilization
of the dollar as an economic weapon
will will shift what's going on right
now from sort of a
tit tat back and forth uh
scrum between the u.s and china to
something that would
that would be elevated to the point
where
you'd start to have to worry about guns
shooting at each other
um so
walk us through huawei you've got some
pretty
strong opinions about huawei um
it's not just another china chinese bad
guy
why have we been so focused on
agriculture to take one example and why
haven't we been more
focused on on huawei why do we pay
attention to tick tock
uh walk me walk me through this
well if you look at the trade side uh
you know i don't want to re-litigate the
last couple of years but
what we've done is prioritize above
absolutely everything else
the idea that we have to get our
bilateral trade deficit
down with china meaning you know they
don't buy enough from us
we buy a lot from them we need to make
that more equal now that sounds fine
uh trade deficits overall might are
something worth watching we should be
trying to balance trade uh bilateral
trade deficit
is it economic is economic nonsense
because you're leaving out third parties
that could be
part of this if we're selling something
to vietnam and vietnam signs into china
and china
the other the other sides of the
triangle are quite important too but
you know to sort of go big picture on
this
we have decided that the trade numbers
and the trade deficits and and making a
more fair trade playing field has been
the most important priority for u.s
uh u.s china policy for the past couple
years and it's it's
what it has done is it's forced us to
miss
some of the bigger issues that are
happening with the relationship
and you brought up huawei always a
perfect example of this
when you talk about the us system the
u.s
model of innovation and markets
and uh that is there's
a really dynamic system and it's
competing against the chinese model
which is dead fueled and
and uh centralized and authoritarian
95 times out of 100 the u.s in a
in a clear playing field will out duel
the chinese model because it's not built
on efficiency it's not built on
innovation
and when you have two countries
competing
on equal playground then let them go
let them go and that's why in general
i'm against the idea of the big tariffs
here etc
the problem is is that there are certain
areas of the economy that don't play by
those rules
now some may know them by by made in
china 2025 which are certain sectors
that
china brought to all of our attention
saying these are advanced manufacturing
sectors that are extremely important to
us
and we want to rule the world in them
going forward and
these are 5g these are robotics
artificial intelligence quantum
computing these type of very important
next generation technologies
now a lot of people say well wait a
second we've got great companies they've
got great companies let's
let's go out let's let's just compete
may the best man win
well that's not what china's doing what
chad has been doing is
using companies like huawei like zte as
foreign policy tools and as heavily
subsidized
entities so for instance you know when
when u.s companies or or
no kid eriksen so these other foreign
companies are doing 5g
are trying to develop technologies and
develop
products you know they're out there
essentially competing
against a chinese giant that has tens of
billions of state subsidies behind it
and the arm of the state pushing huawei
into countries that are taking out that
are borrowing from china that are out
allied with china that want other favors
from china so huawei's being pushed into
these various markets
there's no way you can compete with
certain types of companies
certain sectors of the economy where
beijing has decided
it is is using its centralized power
harnessing its centralized power
to be global champions so if
95 percent of the time u.s model squares
up against the chinese model the us
model will do fine
it will probably win but when china has
decided it's going to take a handful of
companies or a handful of sectors
and make them global champions and these
are going to be
the type of companies that are going to
run the global architecture
telecommunications architecture
cryptological
uh architecture and artificial
intelligence
every part of the the next wave the next
future
future of innovation in the world this
is the next generation of
economic growth exactly so this falls
outside the bucket of two nations
competing
china has decided it's going to make its
champions
the global winners then do you really
need a more concerted
public sector private sector combined
response to push back against them and
look this is this is even leaving out
the fact that huawei and zte and others
have been long-time violators of u.s
sanctions on iran and north korea
you've seen uh you've seen enormous
amounts of intellectual property theft
the doj department of justice right now
has a huge investigation going on and
sort of documenting all the things
huawei's done over the years
so huawei is not just another chinese
company that we need to keep an eye on
it's sort of the vanguard of this
5g push the vanguard to the
the symbolic leader of this made in
china china
made in china 2025 movement and it needs
to it deserves
much more attention from policymakers
than it's getting right now
uh so this is this is something that i
think that people were very
late to wake up to but now congress is
on it the administration's on it
and uh and huawei's going to find a lot
more difficult to compete
when it's not having its way cleared by
the chinese government
with no opposition well it seems like
some of our allies might be coming in
line with this i mean you've heard from
the british that i i think if i'm if i'm
not wrong i think that the british are
going to
start to move away from do you think
that that is something that could
continue
in in the coming years with our allies
it will if we give our allies
the reason to do that i mean one of the
reasons that we've had over the
we haven't had a united front on this is
because while we're telling them to
allow
themselves with us on huawei we're
threatening them with auto tariffs
through the back door
so there has to be more of a unified
foreign policy economic policy
trade policy platform to say look who
what do we want done here what's the
priority is it china
or is it car tariffs in germany and if
you come to the conclusion that we need
to sort of utilize
our our long standing uh
alliances in order to hold china
accountable
for the type of model it has which is
heavily
you know state sector uh subsidized and
and all these other unfair
parts of the parts of the economic model
that have caused havoc across the global
economy
you have to have a foreign policy
position that unites your allies on this
and i think
that's what the trump administration
just has has left us hanging on
i think that's that needs to get more
attention in the coming years so
um i saw a headline a few days ago that
china had made a
a secret pact with iran for 25 years
in this on the security front is was
that
please tell me that was fake news
look i i i assume it's real um
if what beijing has realizing belatedly
right now is its behavior
bullying the whole world has not left it
with a lot of
true friends and so when it looks around
the world well
who would rather be on our side than
america's uh
granted you're seeing a lot more hedging
and hawing and hemming and hawaii
than you saw a few years ago but you
know right now iran's come you know
country number one so i think what
you're going to see is beijing grab it
everybody
anybody and everybody who wants to push
back against u.s leadership
and uh make a big stink about it so is
this good news no
those guys are up to no good but at the
same time i don't think it's surprising
you know we
iran is in our crosshairs on one in
certain for certain issues and beijing's
in our crosshairs for certain other
issues
it it makes a lot of sense for them to
work together to try to frustrate
what we want to get done what about
russia
they kind of share a pretty large border
um what role will russia play in in
alliances theoretically
in the future uh eternal troublemaker
uh russia's in a difficult position
because it's it's a it's a power with a
lot of oil
it's not really a great power uh but has
a lot it has a nice
a nice petrochemical sector and a nice
uh
military industrial complex and likes to
cause trouble around the globe
uh but it has a problem it's obviously
not looking to help america out
but it's it has a long long border with
china
and it has enormous problems with ch
with uh with with beijing
and uh and on that border and and so
russia's in a difficult situation and i
i think that
rather than a grand player in all of
this it's really just an eternal
troublemaker that
we need to sort of make sure we're not
empowering
but uh they don't fall into the same
bucket as
china or rod or others that could really
cause some some serious near-term damage
um taiwan big subject
uh how uh how committed
is the united states where will taiwan
be
in in 50 years
what's your view yeah i wish i knew the
answer to that question
in previous administrations it was very
clear congress supported taiwan
and usually administrations had very
strong
uh political relationships with taiwan
policymakers because you know this these
are things that have been nurtured over
the course of many years and so
you know up until a couple of years ago
i would have been very confident that
if push came to shove uh this the taiwan
relations act which was
written a bit ambiguously but is
essentially interpreted as this
requirement for the united states
to provide not just defense materials
but some form of defense for
taiwan but very ambiguous would be held
up and an american president would say
china don't you dare
we're going to step in here and this is
a vibrant democracy it's not china
and you know don't move any further
we don't know what trump feels about
this i mean i think we do know and he's
i think he sees this as a pawn in this
grand grand game it's very dangerous for
taiwan right now
so a lot of taiwan's in an awful
position it's caught between
the tug and the push and pull of two
enormous great powers
that both have their own designs on it
but both have bigger issues to deal with
china views taiwan as a renegade
province it is china that is the chinese
position we're not going to convince
beijing of anything otherwise
at the same time we have legislative and
political
uh commitments to to taiwan to to to
defend it and so
this ambiguity has served very very well
in the past
particularly when the us military was so
much more powerful than the chinese
military that
there wasn't really a question of how a
skirmish would end up
not so much anymore so with with the
rising u.s china tensions with taiwan
being being sort of pulled from each
side
uh with the chinese military on the rise
particularly in the pacific region
this gets a lot hairier so before we
move on to the south china sea
in our tour of the world uh
semiconductors in taiwan
there's a very practical reason that
china wants to keep such a stronghold as
well what is that relationship
yeah so one of the reasons taiwan's
being talked about now it hasn't really
gotten that much press in terms of you
know will beijing invade or block hate
it
part of this is because when one country
two systems fell in hong kong
uh it basically destroyed the model that
china had been promising taiwan
if it just came back under the fold hey
look we'll let you be
just just trust us and now hong kong
has shown that that model doesn't work
and so there is no longer a workable
model
for taiwan to look at they are an
independent country or they will be
a conquered chinese province there's
really no in between anymore
so so that was a serious change
in the way that i think the taiwanese
have looked at their future uh but you
get but like you said semiconductors are
another piece of the puzzle
the most important semiconductor company
in the world right now
is probably taiwan semiconductor they
make all the chips that huawei
and others use uh in and all their
devices worldwide so
yes in their phones but the real ones
that are important are in 5g base
stations
without taiwan semi providing those
chips and they're very advanced ships
they're ones that the chinese domestic
industry
cannot make at this point and will not
be able to make any times soon
without providing these chips huawei as
a company
could die and so there is an enormous
stranglehold
that taiwan's semiconductor has over a
critical
chinese company and and actually the
entire 5g effort which is which is
important
uh component of xi jinping's economic
policy so you've got this enormous
position of power for taiwan
semiconductor which of course the u.s
side has said hey
we know what you can do you can go build
a a factory in arizona which they're
trying to try to move some of the
production onto
to u.s land in order to to to tighten
the uh relationship we're trying to let
that happen
uh well it's already been announced they
haven't actually done anything
uh china can't stop them from doing that
but it can
it can start pushing taiwan and other
aspects of the relationship
but they've got another problem here so
the department of commerce
uh a year ago huawei went on the entity
list everyone someone said wow that
sounds like
such a tough thing that must really shut
down
while we had record revenues that year
anyways didn't do a thing you know we've
been talking about this the entity list
is not and it's
something that stops production for
huawei it didn't do anything to huawei
but what the department of commerce has
done in the last couple of us department
of commerce has done the last couple of
months
has been something more advanced and
they came out with something called the
foreign product rule
which requires any
uh chip producer that uses us inputs and
that
importantly includes taiwan
semiconductor must
file for a license from the u.s
department of commerce
in order to provide it to huawei or or
several other entities
so right now unless the department of
commerce gives
taiwan semiconductor a license to
operate with huawei
the us department of commerce can can
can put a
hold on taiwan semiconductor which could
put a a strangle hold on huawei and end
them
now if this sounds as is as dangerous
as it as it as it does it is it really
is
now the question is does donald trump
want to go there will they actually
shut down huawei as a company with all
the
secondary implications that would have
on the relationship
and on the the end of the trade deal and
other things they're not there yet
but i think what huawei is now looking
at and the chinese
government is now looking at is this
enormous stranglehold
that the us government has on certain of
its champions and the enormous
stranglehold the taiwan semiconductor in
particular has on a couple of his
champions
and this only confuses and makes
more difficult any predictions on taiwan
because
now everybody now everybody's in in a
real dangerous bubble here and
we don't know how it's gonna end up so
um
now we can go to the south china sea and
the u.s navy
and what has happened if you look back
at the obama administration
i think that that on the world stage it
was determined that the build-out in the
south china sea was in violation
of international law but it was nobody
ever did anything about it
it's continued from what i understand
walk us through what their military
presence is i mean when we were
when we were speaking offline before the
interview you you mentioned the word
missiles
uh what is happening there what are we
doing there
and what is the potential until recently
we were doing almost nothing and that
that's under obama that's under trump uh
and one of the reasons why
what's happening on the ground right now
has become a reality the chinese are
ensconced there they're not going to be
able to be pulled out of those positions
we have a new reality in the south china
sea uh
but i think that uh there there's two
different
issues when we talk about south china
sea the first one is
uh china is militarizing some of their
islands
and and they've also created little
rocks in the middle of nowhere and clams
eezs
off of them and the problem here is that
in the south china sea you've got a
bunch of islands and typically and this
gets a little bit wonky when you're
talking to
you know wall of the sea a possession
a you know whether it's vietnamese or
chinese or malaysian or
any other is is granted 200 miles around
it it's called an eez
an economic exclusion zone where
that company that country has
sovereignty in that area
and a lot of these eezs overlap with
each other because you've got a lot of
rocks in the south china sea
so there's a lot of adjudications that
need to be happening china has basically
decided
that there's something called the nine
dash line which is a map it made up one
day
which just encompasses the whole south
china sea and they said hey that's ours
uh where'd you get this map oh it's been
around for like a thousand years
where'd you get it from that's been
around for a thousand years just trust
this this thing called the nine dash
line
this is our stuff and so they are
are saying that all these eez from the
philippines and from vietnam and from
all these other countries taiwan
um are actually chinese waters so stay
out of them they've also been
militarizing certain rocks which are
literally just rocks that they're
building up with sand
with sand and and and bringing
construction crews in and creating you
know man-made islands
and they're putting a mis a person in a
missile on top of them and saying
hey these are this chinese land stay
away um
now what has been happening here south
china sea has been totally ignored the
last three years
because of course we had to worry about
soybeans
but the reason it's becoming back into
this is that
people are realizing that south china
sea is not about
the u.s china policy battle it's not
even about
whether vietnam or whether the
philippines or whether taiwan gets
control of any particular island
it's all about freedom of navigation
the us interest in this has always been
that we will use our navy to ensure that
all these international waters
will be free for commerce south china
sea is one of the largest uh
gateways for commerce the entire world
and we will keep that free
and we the principle of freedom of
navigation and open commerce
is something that is absolutely up in
tier one priorities
as a national security enters the united
states not whether the vietnamese get an
island not whether the chinese get
another island but
freedom of navigation in the south china
sea like everywhere else in the world is
absolutely critical to u.s security
and what's happening all these chinese
pushes
and and refusal refusals to adhere to
international rulings have caused there
to be a real question
to whether the chinese think that they
can block off this area from
for from commerce including you the
united states uh
u.s ships u.s military etc people have
not wanted to deal with this for a while
i think the chinese have been very
content to just establish their reality
on the ground for years
why get in the fight now we can just
keep building up these islands and
putting missiles on it
u.s presidents have refused to do
anything about it except the occasional
sail through
well now i think we're realizing that
this is a real problem and so
going forward this is not just about
defending an ally or taking a smaller
country side against a bigger allies
or a bigger country like china that's
bullying them this is about freedom of
navigation and it's why the south china
sea
is such an enormous geopolitical risk
because if the chinese decide
to block off any of these channels the
u.s
military has to bl has to run the
blockade
it has to even if that brings us to war
and the chinese know that but here we
are
and things are a lot more dangerous in
well so i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
i'm gonna hop on my twitter feed for
just a second
anytime any little thing happens with
china
and you these just these discussions
come up
the immediate reply is well the u.s is
going to lose its
reserve currency status
how feasible is that even if something
was to come to pass
how feasible is it that there's this
deeply held conviction that because the
united states continues to run up its
debts
because we rely on 36 percent of our
outstanding treasuries are
owned by foreigners can we lose this
reserve currency status
that's nonsense it's nonsense uh not not
that we can't help your enemies
and look i i get tomatoes throne thrown
at me for this one but look
yes i can think of a scenario where the
u.s loses
its reserve currency status but it's not
because someone else takes it there are
no other contenders for reserve currency
status right now
it's not the chinese who don't have a
deep enough bond market who don't have
uh free convertibility chinese are not
even sort of a contender
and will never be anytime soon they're
going the other direction who's the
other contenders at the euro the yen
i'm not even talking about bitcoin uh
too small so when you're talking about a
global reserve currency
uh you have to have something that has
all the advantages that the dollar
brings
even if you have all this political
uncertainty which is starting to come
along with it
so there is no next currency up to bat
the only way the u.s loses reserve
currency any time in the near future
is if the united states
shoots itself in the foot and loses all
its credibility
yeah your your eyebrows are up because
this has suddenly become a real
possibility
look when we started talking about the
advertising drinking a lot of money
leland we're running up
we're running up deficits the likes of
which we've never seen before
and we're headed into election but go on
i agree but i i don't think that they
lose it because they print too much
money
i'm not in favor of this i'm scared out
of my mind where we're going next
uh but everybody's putting a lot of
money and i think i think that the
problem here is this
that when you start threatening u.s
treasury
abrogating you know u.s debt obligations
to china and you start saying well maybe
the united states isn't going to pay
back
what it's owed these are not really ious
this is an international
this that's not how it works but if you
start talking about the fact that the
united states will not honor its
obligation
as the uh you know the lender of last
resort and as the as the reserve
currency
then all of a sudden you start bringing
doubts into people's minds whether their
investments in the us dollar
in the u.s and the american economy are
good and
while there is no currency they can rip
the global reserve currency uh you know
status away from the united states
dollar
and there's no country that can do it
the united states could do some really
really really stupid things
lose credibility and i think in that
case rather than having another reserve
currency
jump up you start breaking into regional
blocks
it would become a very different world
but because there's not an air apparent
here
it's not going to happen anytime soon
unless enormously stupid
policy decisions are made so stupid in
fact
that even when stupid policies have been
discussed over the last
three years these were not one of them
so i'll tell you
they has to be next generation stupid
for this day
no boy uh well speaking of which uh
why don't we circle back to the beltway
uh
in just a few months we have a
presidential election
do you see because i you know
do you ever see china as
not being a focal point in u.s policy
circles
regardless of what the outcome of the
election is let's say biden wins
do you ever see the united states
stepping back the unrealization of the
importance of huawei
and the future of technology and the
future of innovation
um will china remain
on the front burner regardless of who's
running congress regardless of who's in
the white house
yes absolutely and i think this is
something that it's very well understood
by both
uh biden and trump the election is going
to be dictated
in large part by what happens with covet
of course but beyond that
this is about china and i think that uh
the reason that trump has not gone
harder against china now you're seeing
an announcement every day
looking like they're sort of turning up
the temperature well they haven't really
done anything yet
because the president wants to keep his
phase one trade deal
when it becomes too difficult to keep a
whether it's a day from now a week from
now or a few months from now
president pulls back you lose the trade
deal all of a sudden you can go much
much harder
and i think the last card that the
president would want to play if he
didn't think he could run on economic
leadership or
a great recovery in the fall will be i'm
the toughest guy on china that's why you
need to elect me
and right now uh we're heading and we'll
fall which is probably going to be the
worst relations that
anyone's seen since tiananmen if not
worse than that tiananmen square in 1989
in other words uh the crack down there
where things got really icy
we are heading into a really really bad
period in u.s china relations
and one of the issues here is that the
leverage points that the americans have
are far greater than anything the
chinese have which makes the chinese
very nervous
and and it's why when we talk about
things like south china sea
or taiwan other things like that these
should not
normally be brought up in a conversation
but if you lack leverage and you're
trying to show that china will not be
pushed around
some of the things that have been off
the radar
but also off the list of possibilities
for years and years and years are
suddenly becoming possible right now
it's a very very dangerous time
and the problem is no matter who wins
this is not going away this is going to
be
the new great power competition
going forward and i don't think there's
any reversing out of this
so um let's not let's not go to
uh covert 19 and we'll we'll we'll end
here
uh because i think things have changed
for china
in a post-covet world in terms of uh
countries that would have never stood up
to china that maybe now
because their economies have been so
harmed by this virus
there were 116 com other countries
besides australia
that demanded an independent inquiry at
the world health organization for
example
i think 12 months ago we would have
never seen such a showing
how badly has coveted
harmed china's standing in the world
because of what it's done
to so many economies uh
i think kovat has harmed china's
standing i think kovit has caused
beijing
to do enormously stupid things that have
badly badly
hurt china's standing uh and and i'll
explain what
i mean by that uh obviously having the
the virus originate coronavirus
originate in beijing
has caught made a lot of people angry
the average person off the street is
angry at china for having originated
this
absolutely you've got that dynamic but
in addition
this has caused so much domestic angst
you know coming on top of
the trade war coming on top of the
problems in hong kong coming on top of
all the other challenges with the
slowing economy beijing's dealing with
right now
that they've sort of taken their
playbook for the last couple years in
terms of being this
goodwill international champion and they
haven't just
they haven't just dropped it or put it
behind them they've lit it on fire and
throwing it off the
out the window uh all the goodwill that
they were starting to build up when
people were starting to get tired of
trump trump's uh take and and and
and they were trying to capitalize that
at international institutions uh
it's all gone because essentially china
went after everybody they put their
wolf warriors on twitter uh they
attacked australia they attacked canada
they had
they insulted france their attack in the
uk uh
they attacked africa and africans in
china have
faced a very difficult time uh with
racism
look it's it's it's basically gone that
a very dark road
and when you look at that as an outsider
it's very difficult to figure out what
they're talking about
all they needed to do is continue to
smile
to say we apologize this came from us
but we're going to ship you ventilators
we're going to ship you masks
we are going to be your friend we
figured out how to beat it
earlier than anybody else we figured out
how to contain it and
we're going to be the world leader on
this and i think had they kept that
particularly how poorly a lot of other
countries
like the united states are handling
kovit it would have been a very powerful
message of goodwill
that could have allowed them to escape
this this tunnel that they were digging
themselves into
uh but apparently that's not what the
political imperative was in beijing the
political imperative in beijing
was we need to rally around the flag we
need to convince everybody that
everyone back home that the world's gang
up on us and we needed to shoot out and
get real aggressive with everybody
and tell them china won't be trifled
with and by the way
we didn't start the virus you start the
virus and
it's really done enormous damage to the
china's international position over the
last six months
maybe she knows something that we don't
and things are a lot hairier at home and
he thought that he needed to do this in
order to secure political support
certainly the numbers we're seeing for
political support in china are going up
right now
so maybe this is a clever plan
but the way the world looks at it
enormously silly way to go about
business
so um one last question leland
a lot of americans are out of work right
now
uh obviously the the economy is in a
situation that it has not been in
in generations plural uh
how many chinese are out of work right
now
what is their for the man on the ground
for the woman on the ground
how is the chinese economy right now
from the perspective of the worker
well it's very interesting because the
most opaque part
of the most opaque economy is is the
jobs market
right we track this and you know when we
ask firms what they were seeing they
were seeing improvement from q1 and
but you know when we started digging
down into the questions we say well wait
a second you're reporting more hiring
are these furloughed workers that you
never reported as laid off that you're
reporting hiring back
and we find some very interesting
answers their
companies are being ordered governments
are being ordered to keep
that jobs number in a very tight window
there is no way you have six percent
unemployment right now
when a think tank in china came out with
a with a claim that you'd seeing over 20
that guy mysteriously lost his position
or not so mysteriously lost his position
you know what do we think is going on
here of course we know what's going on
here
they're not acknowledging huge chunks of
the economy that are unemployed
there's a floating migrant population
which is hard to track
but beijing sort of ignores it when it's
inconvenient to talk about layoffs there
so you are seeing the effects of covid
no one's immune to these you're seeing
widespread losses in the retail and
services sector in particular
across all these different countries and
china is is
is in a similar position so they have
handled it in some ways
better than other countries but the idea
that they're reporting right now
this this much better data jobs are back
to normal and
growth is almost back to normal total
nonsense and
it's a problem going forward because
right now policy makers who just
want to hear good news are listening to
what beijing says and well hey
china's getting better that's us two or
three months from now but what's coming
out of china
is not what's actually happening in
china it's a sanitized political message
and that's why it's it's so important to
be having these conversations and to be
talking about what's really happening
in the economic data and in the jobs
data
well i'd like to thank you for all this
time i mean i think our
eyes are a lot wider open than they were
before as we sit here in this
very soviet-like cold war with china
um thanks so much for spending the time
be safe
and hopefully the next time we do this
it'll be face to face that was my
pleasure and i'm looking forward to it
thank you